I love that you guys have kind of been
on like a little World Tour and I have
to say I think multi has more passport
stamps than I do already
yeah she's a little traveler um
my parents raised me like that so was my
husband we went with them my dad and mom
both were in the military we started
traveling when I was very young
um when I was like four or five months
uh so the same thing for her uh right
now she's not in school so we can schlep
or wherever we want right um also love
spending time with her so it's cool
you're a spy like me if you touch me I'm
gonna scream catch
we're gonna catch it okay you were
quoted as saying look I earned my scars
for this show tell me about the
preparation for this series what went
into it
it was a lot of work I won't I mean I
won't lie we shot it over a year and a
half we had
um to really push ourselves to be
physically you know at the best
um because anything could come up at any
time the stunts required a lot
um it was physically heavy but also you
know emotionally daunting we shot it
during 2021 we were all like
um you know in a bubble
um but shooting with the russos and on
the show they really gave us incredible
resources to be able to pull off
whatever these stunts needed you know um
Richard used to wake up at three o'clock
in the morning and work out that wasn't
me though
I don't know people do that
tell me more the alarm goes off at 3am
you're like oh my God it's so boring him
it's so boring it's so boring it's
boring doing it and it's boring talking
about it no it's not it's it's a lot of
I mean that's crazy it's amazing you're
so focused yeah I'll be like get up like
two and then work out for a couple hours
and then
couldn't get your makeup on and then go
and fight all day and then work till
like for about 10 15 10 12 hour day 10
to 12 hour day yeah and then they start
practice it was it was a lot but it
looks good in the end yeah it looks
amazing
we did it feels like a sense of
achievement it looks so good what is
your favorite stunt you did
or maybe the most challenging as well
most challenging the bathroom fight was
challenging because I like I'm fighting
this huge guy in a very small space but
that's what was kind of really fun about
it was going okay how do we use this
space to your advantage because I'm like
they're not going to believe I can fight
this guy he's huge I'll believe anything
you sell Madden but then that teaches
you about the character you're like okay
well what would he do right he'd the
floor's just limited let's use the wall
as a floor I'll run up that and get
around this guy we have amazing leads
we're working with the russos but I
gotta know Stanley Tucci what was it
like working with him Sam is the best to
work with especially in a piece like
this which is so high stakes heavy life
for death and Stanley can can make
says he's just so clever and like I love
his baritone voice I'm always like just
keep talking Stanley just explain to me
what we're doing in this scene I see you
left me a few new toys yes I built them
for my favorite spot oh he hated them
and I didn't want them to go to waste
you guys have done a range from like
rom-com's menacing action is there an
itch that you feel like either of you
have not scratched yet that you would
love to do in your career
I mean I have a lot I I feel like
um in my Hindi language or Bollywood
career I did many many variety of genres
and Bots and I feel like in my English
language work I want to do a lot more of
that drama I don't know what it is but
um that's something I want to explore a
little bit of what about you I'd like to
do something in common I know it's nice
to not I mean we go to work every day
and we're like we're gonna die
killed so many times did something fun
for a minute can I do something fun I'm
putting that out there something
something in the comedy you heard it
here first
[Music]
foreign